[Music]
right now wherever you are you are
spinning with our planet at a speed of
hundreds of meters per second
but what if our planet started hitting
the brakes until our world didn't spin
at all
why would it be harder for you to move
around
why would some parts of the world
actually benefit from this
and why could this slowdown provide you
with the trip of a lifetime
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Earth gradually came to a
standstill
Earth's rotation on its axis is the
reason why you experience day and night
over the 24 hours that it takes to do a
full spin
except it doesn't rotate evenly
everywhere
at the Equator the speed is over 460
meters per second
but the closer you get to the poles the
slower our planet turns
whether it's north or south the
rotational speed is almost zero
millions of years ago it only took Earth
22 hours to spin on its axis and with
every passing Century our days become
two milliseconds longer
now if that deceleration intensified and
the planet went to a complete standstill
within a year
you might have to get used to a daily
dose of catastrophe
the first sign that the great slowdown
is underway would be radical changes in
the weather
this is because as the Earth rotates it
gives rise to the Coriolis effect
air in the northern hemisphere is
deflected to the right while in the
southern hemisphere it's deflected to
the left
this also means that hot air veers away
from the poles
but as the planet slowed down the Warm
Winds from the equator would slowly
start to make their way to the top and
bottom of the globe and in the meantime
cool air from the poles would also sink
back down to the equator
these changes in Wind patterns would
have disastrous consequences they would
drive rainfall and raise temperatures
around the world
pure summer Cottage in the forest could
become surrounded by a sprawling desert
and where a frozen tundra once stood
farmable land could emerge
these changes would disrupt ecosystems
around the world unable to adapt plants
and animals would die
on the other hand the days of hurricanes
would be numbered coriolis forces create
hurricanes and without them they just
wouldn't form
and the changes to the world around you
wouldn't end there
our planet would begin to ease up on the
spinning but by no means would the
ground stay put
you see Earth is like an onion it's made
up of layers
crust the mantle and the core
and as the onion we call home slowed
down
these layers might not do so in unison
this would result in intense friction
between them which equals tremors and
lava
The year-long Slowdown would be a deluge
of earthquakes and volcanic eruptions
Sweden Saudi Arabia and other regions
not accustomed to these natural
disasters would get their taste
if you made it to the other side of this
shaky and heated period well you'd be
rewarded with a planet where seismic
activity would be a thing of the past
now the ocean is where you'd witness the
most astounding changes to our shared
home
you see those globes at school tricked
you
Earth is not a perfect sphere it bulges
at the equator
this is a result of the centrifugal
force caused by you guessed it the
planet's rotation
as it turns Earth gets squished and its
equatorial diameter becomes 43
kilometers longer than the polar radius
as Earth slowed down its middle bump
would shrink
the oceans would start to Flow Away from
the equator and Rush toward the poles if
you lived near the beach you noticed its
Coastline receding
clear sign that something is wrong
and hope your house by the water isn't
in the northern region of our planet
Canada the United States and Greenland
could be swallowed by the big blue sea
as would the northern regions of Siberia
Asia and Europe
sorry about that
now things would look much brighter in
the South as the oceans pulled to the
poles new land would be extending out
Africa would now merge with Madagascar
Australia and New Guinea and eventually
Indonesia would make the shift
by the time the year is over and Earth
arrives at a standstill the equatorial
region would be completely drained
leaving behind a giant mega continent
a chunk of real estate so massive that
it would Circle the entire world
splitting the ocean in two
we'll call it the ring no not that ring
this one is literally more
groundbreaking
this gargantuan landmass would allow you
to walk the entire strip of the Equator
on foot
travel companies would capitalize on the
mega continent to offer you packages to
track the circumference of our planet on
foot
forget Everest manage this Monumental
feat and you could brag to your friends
about conquering the ring that's cool
naturally you wouldn't be the only one
up for the journey
the slower the Earth spun the longer our
days and nights would become and once
the rotation stops completely one day on
Earth would last six months
during half year Cycles the planet would
see extreme temperature fluctuations
from a freezing minus 55 degrees Celsius
to a scorching plus 55 degrees Celsius
not to mention a complete breakdown of
our biological circadian rhythms
six months of darkness could lead to a
spike in skeletal deformities and dental
issues thanks to a global shortage of
natural vitamin D
you could also expect an influx of
seasonal affective disorder with
symptoms such as loss of energy
oversleeping and feelings of
hopelessness
so traveling the ring would be as much
about remaining within a weather sweet
spot as it would be about going on an
adventure
not that gravity would be on your side
for it
as Earth slows down you'd notice you
have a harder time moving around
you wouldn't look heavier but your
bathroom scale would say otherwise
that's because a spinning Earth produces
an outward centrifugal force which
cancels a portion of its gravity
no rotation means you get to experience
the full gravitational pull
and with that comes the sensation of
feeling like you've packed on a few
extra kilos
get off the scale eventually things
would get worse our planet's magnetic
field partially produced by its rotation
would disappear and expose you to
harmful solar radiation
human civilization would be left dealing
with frequent vital service outages and
irreparable damage to power grids
internet connections and navigation
systems
but if Earth suddenly stopped spinning
overnight
a defective smartphone would be the
least of your worries
you and even the very crust of our
planet would be in quite a pickle
Wait Wait Don't hop off just yet you
know you can never really trust the
algorithm to deliver your favorite video
so to make sure you don't miss any of
our episodes or a special announcement
coming up in a few weeks sign up for our
newsletter you'll also get exclusive
merch discounts giveaways and be the
first to know about everything new
happening at what if and that's not all
click on the link below to get our free
top 10 book